dismal reviews bad word of mouth or was
this historical epic just a little too
epic and lame here's why Babylon bombed
and bombed big at the box office
Babylon had a production budget of 110
million dollars which probably has gone
to the huge cast as well as the
intricate and decadent set designs
colorful in sweeping the film features
plenty of dizzying scenes of parties
revelers and mind-numbing Hedonism which
probably helps to explain where some of
that budget went unfortunately the movie
didn't do great during its opening week
making a paltry 3.6 million dollars in
3343 domestic theaters although still
freshly released in theaters projections
for Babylon are beginning to look quite
abysmal although many outlets weren't
exactly projecting a massive haul for
Babylon some expected the film to make
at least its money back in late November
Box Office Pro predicted that the movie
would have both positives and negatives
that may affect its Financial prowess on
the positive side Babylon is a Prestige
comedy with the star-static cast on the
negative side the early reviews weren't
exactly the greatest and historical film
films tend to be hit or miss with many
audiences they projected Babylon would
make four to nine million dollars in its
first week with a grand total of between
18 to 39 million in domestic totals
gaming Zion made a bold although
somewhat tempered bet on Babylon as well
saying the gambling experts predicted a
five to six million dollar opening
weekend if I had money I would only
spend it on things that were fun as we
mentioned earlier some of the reviews
for Babylon weren't exactly strong which
may have impacted theatergoers
willingness to Brave the winter weather
and catch the flick on the big screen on
Rotten Tomatoes Babylon currently has a
55 critic rating at the time of this
writing in the review of the film Salon
claimed that Babylon is exhausting
finding that the movie tries to do
entirely too much over its run time
though ends up saying very little by the
movie's combination similarly splice
today wrote that the first 90 minutes of
Babylon is a hit in the making but on 4
fortunately the movie continues on for
another 90 minutes Leonard Malton
offered a slightly more nuanced take on
the movie and said I didn't love Babylon
but I can't condemn it either how could
I when his finale is a love letter to
movies and the way they can lift our
Spirits I think what we have here in
Hollywood is high Arts
many critics have pointed out the
exceptionally long run time of the movie
which is 3 hours and 9 Minutes of
absolute heartbreak and debauchery a
daunting endurance experience for
viewers and one that may have proven to
be too much for some speaking with
collider director Damien chazelle
explained that editing the movie proved
to be a difficult process saying that
many of the scenes were cut but
eventually restored and this became
somewhat of a back and forth throughout
post-production
I've been working on this movie for
almost 15 years
Gisele added that at one point Babylon
ballooned to 3 hours and 40 minutes and
that he and the editing crew had to chip
it back down Gisele continued we
definitely did not want it to ever feel
like a three plus hour movie we wanted
people to come out of it feeling like
they'd been on an Unstoppable roller
coaster and then be almost surprised by
how long it was it's the biggest thing
I've ever tried to do another aspect
that may impact box office performance
for Babylon is the negative feedback
loop created by articles claiming that
the movie has bombed or is in the
process of doing so nobody is exactly
champing at the bit to go see a movie
shrouded in negative articles and one
doesn't have to spend too much time
reading the news to see what we're
talking about deadline ran an article
with a headline that claims that
audiences were not jazzed for Babylon
and that the movie has failed to meet
expectations resulting in an
unquestionably massive box office bomb
variety and Vanity Fair also mentioned
Babylon and its failure to generate
significant Revenue during its opening
run even MovieWeb ran an article
claiming that Babylon is the second flop
this year for Star Margot Robbie noting
that her Ensemble movie Amsterdam was
also a misfire these are just a few
examples but it does highlight how
negative press can have somewhat of a
Snowball Effect if you could go anywhere
in the whole world where would you go
perhaps the biggest reason why Babylon
hasn't attracted many large audiences
comes down to one big blue reason
despite the fact that the holiday movie
going experience doesn't exactly have
too many adult oriented movies currently
available the success of Babylon may
have been hindered by the sequel to one
of the biggest movies of all time Avatar
the way of water a long simmering
continuation of the story presented in
avatar The Way of water is slowly
charting its way to box off a success we
cannot let you bring your War here as
noted by the Numbers Avatar the way of
water is just shy of one billion dollars
in box office sales at the time of
writing which represents the vast
majority of theater going experiences
over the past few weeks the draw and
spectacle of Avatar the way of water may
have been enough to cut into the
audience that was initially interested
in Babylon which may only represent a
small sliver of ticket sales however
families aren't exactly taking their
children to see a movie about the rise
and fall of 1920s Hollywood that ends on
a relatively dour note at least when one
considers that specific period of time
still there seems to be a multitude of
reasons as to why Babylon has been
unable to climb to the heights it had
Ambitions for though there certainly is
a chance that the movie will experience
a Resurgence in interest during award
season even though Babylon has been
somewhat divisive among critics all
agree on one thing Margot Robbie's
performance is definitely worth some
accolades
[Music]
foreign
[Music]